Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this paper, you will not only see an amazing
technique for two-way coupled fluid-solid
simulations, but you will also see some of
the most creative demonstrations of this new
method I’ve seen in a while.
But first things first, what is this two way
coupling thing?
Two-way coupling in a fluid simulation means
being able to process contact.
You see, the armadillos can collide with the
fluids, but the fluids are also allowed to
move the armadillos.
And this new work can compute this kind of
contact.
And by this I mean lots and lots of contact.
But one of the important lessons of this paper
is that we don’t necessarily need a scene
this crazy to be dominated by two-way coupling.
Have a look at this experiment with these
adorable duckies, and below, the propellers
are starting up, please don’t be one of
those graphics papers.
Okay..okay, good.
We dodged this one.
So the propellers are not here to dismember
things, they are here to spin up to 160 rpm,
and since they are two-way coupled, they pump
water from one tank to the other, raising
the water levels, allowing the duckies to
pass.
An excellent demonstration of a proper algorithm
that can compute two-way coupling really well.
And simulating this scene is much, much more
challenging than we might think.
Why is that?
Note that the speed of the propellers is quite
high, which is a huge challenge to previous
methods.
If we wish to complete the simulation in a
reasonable amount of time, it simulates the
interaction incorrectly and no ducks can pass.
The new technique can simulate this correctly,
and not only that, but it is also 4.5 times
faster than the previous method.
Also, check out this elegant demonstration
of two-way coupling.
We start slowly unscrewing this bolt…and…nothing
too crazy going on here.
However, look!
We have tiny cutouts in the bolt, allowing
the water to start gushing out.
The pipe was made transparent so we can track
the water levels slowly decreasing, and finally,
when the bolt falls out, we get some more
two-way coupling action with the water.
Once more, such a beautiful demonstration
of a difficult to simulate phenomenon.
Loving it.
A traditional technique cannot simulate this
properly, unless we add a lot of extra computation.
At which point, it is still unstable… ouch!
And with even more extra computation, we can
finally do this, but hold on to your papers,
because the new proposed technique can do
it about 10 times faster.
It also supports contact against rich geometry
as well.
Look, we have a great deal going on here.
You are seeing up to 38 million fluid particles
interacting with these walls given with lots
of rich geometry, and there will be interaction
with mud, and elastic trees as well.
This can really do them all.
And did you notice that throughout this video,
we saw a lot of delta t-s.
What are those?
Delta t is something that we call time step
size.
The smaller this number is, the tinier the
time steps with which we can advance the simulation
when computing every interaction, and hence,
the more steps there are to compute.
In simpler words, generally, time step size
is an important factor in the computation
time, and the smaller this is, the slower,
but more accurate the simulation will be.
This is why we needed to reduce the time steps
by more than 30 times to get a stable simulation
here with the previous method.
And this paper proposes a technique that can
get away with time steps that are typically
from 10 times to a 100 times larger than previous
methods.
And it is still stable.
That is an incredible achievement.
So what does that mean in a practical case?
Well, hold on to your papers, because this
means that it is up to 58 times faster than
previous methods.
58 times!
Whoa.
With a previous method, I would need to run
something for nearly two months, and the new
method would be able to compute the same within
a day.
Witchcraft, I’m telling you.
What a time to be alive!
Also, as usual, I couldn’t resist creating
a slow-motion version of some of these videos,
so if this is something that you wish to see,
make sure to visit our Instagram page in the
video description
for more.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!